Speaker 1: We are taking calls from you without
you, I'm a guy in a room with a mic talking to
the wall, and it's sad. It's very sad. But
with you guys here, this is actually a show.
We take calls via discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord, and it is a it's a great thing.
It's really a great thing. Let's go next. Where
are we going next? Let's go to Houston and
speak to her. Hear her here. You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I'm originally from Mexico,
but I've lived here in Houston my whole life. And
we have a very Trump like president right now and
makes a very narcissistic authoritarian. His last
sort of hint that he was going towards this very
authoritarian. L was he hinted that he liked
Putin and he wasn't going to do any sanctions.
So all this, all this is, was sort of he sort
of came to popularity around Trump also. What
do you think it is that people are so attracted
to these narcissistic clown authoritarian types?
Speaker 1: So I don't know that much about the
authoritarian piece. I mean, I know about the
sort of narcissism and I but but it is at least
ostensibly a left leaning coalition in Mexico
right now. I mean, I guess what you're telling
me is that in practice, it's authoritarian.
Speaker 2: Yeah, so he is sort of taken over the
military and they're doing sort of his policing.
He's trying to strengthen the military to
to to sort of solidify his power. Another
play he wanted was to amend the Constitution so he
could stay in power for another term. Thankfully,
he didn't win the Congress, so he can't
really do that. But it's those sort of things.
Speaker 1: And so you're wondering what
it is about these authoritarians that
is appealing to people?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: I think it's it's it's sort of basic
crowd psychology to some degree, and the idea that
some some idea, some ideologies are easier to sell
than others. And so like, for example, populism,
populism is not a set of policies that, as I've
talked about before, populism is really a rhetoric
and that so when we say left wing populism or
right wing populism, we're not really talking
about policy. Some people will say there's no
such thing as right wing populism, right? Well,
it's just it's rhetoric. It's populist
rhetoric from right wingers or left wingers,
and populist rhetoric is very appealing to a lot
of people. The devil is in. What policies do you
follow it up with? You see populist rhetoric from
the left, and it's like Bernie policies, and then
you see populist rhetoric from the right. And
it's like, Yeah, and the problem. The reason for
all our problems is, you know, brown people from
Mexico. And so we've got to just stop them from
coming in. So I think that the Trump types, Putin
types, et cetera, there is a large population base
that loves the strongman of sorts, and it's just
appealing no matter what policy is behind it.
And that that's why it works so often.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes sense,
it just I found it very weird how Trump's policies
are very different from sort of these liberal
policies coming from Mexico. Yes. They're they're
the same type of person, you know, the narcissist
wanting to take control, manipulating people
lying all the time. And it just seemed people
were really attracted to that 100 percent.
Speaker 1: And unfortunately, sometimes
it can work for a long time.
It does. It doesn't, obviously
fail. And I mean, listen, we're seeing
we're seeing it around the world. It's not.
There's many places around the world where
we're seeing exactly that, and it's horrifying.
Speaker 2: Yeah, very scary.
Speaker 1: Thank you, David. All
right, thank you for the call. Very much.
Appreciate it. Let's go next to Dave from
Brooklyn. Dave, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello, can hear me. Yes,
I can. Our longtime listener call, but
I'm just calling because I wanted to get
a little more perspective on you from you
because you've been talking a lot recently about
issues that we're facing as a left and after
listening to the union address last night.
I feel like you saw all over the place with so
little focus. You just kind of reinforce the
message that you've been saying for a while that
has left the progressive. We have no focus. And
I was wondering what you were in charge? What are
the like the two or three or four things you would
focus in on and get on to start bringing
people back into our our fold politically?
Yeah, that's a good question.
Speaker 1: Is there a TV in the background
because it's very tough to hear you over it?
Speaker 2: Oh, no worries, I can disconnected,
just listen to the answer.
Speaker 1: OK. All right.
Yeah. So listen, if I think that yes, one of the
one of my critiques of the State of the Union was
that it really was all over the place with like no
transitions whatsoever Joe Biden was going from.
We're going to control prices when businesses
are charging too much without saying why,
too. We're going to change taxes and we're
stopping flights from Russia and we're going
to beat cancer. And you know, all these. It was
it was very much all over the place, which is OK,
it's OK for a state of the Union to lay out a big
vision that includes a lot of different things.
If it were me right now saying the left has
to be focused, I would try to narrow things
a little bit and say, OK, we've got it. Pick one
or two things on the economic justice front. So
there's all these different things. There's
minimum wage totally changing the tax code.
Undoing tax loopholes. Student loan debt. All
these different things. I would I would say,
like, let's pick two specific things on the
economic side that we're going to do. Let's come
up with a pro-business plan on the environment
and really just lay out again one or two things.
Here's the lowest hanging fruit on how we can both
support business and help the environment, and
whether it's a green energy focus or whatever.
Find like two things there. And then thirdly,
make some kind of clear statement. To some
degree, I hope about the state of democracy
and simplify what really needs to be done to take
the narrative back that from those who on the
right who are now saying elections just can't
be trusted and anybody could have really won,
you'd have no way of knowing that's very dangerous
and demoralizing. It also happens to be untrue.
So I think that's what I would do. I would say,
number one, let let's get just a simple message
out there to undo all of this stuff that's been
opened up about the Big Lie and Trump really won
and all that. We got to put a stop to that and
get people really thinking clearly about what's
actually going on. Number two, let's do something
that feels good about the environment, but that
also is very clearly not going to be back. Quote
bad for business the way many on the right say
anything we do to deal with climate change, it's
going to be terrible for business. No, it doesn't
have to be that way. And then again, on something
economic, just pick say we're going to make these
three changes to the tax code and we'll pay ten
grand of student debt. That's it. And then you
you have to restrict the conversation. And this
will upset some people. Some people say no,
but you're not including minimum wage in
that or you didn't include this. I get it.
You can't ever do anything. So why even
pretend like you can? Let's really narrow
the message and say, here's what what we're
going to get done. That would be my suggestion